Так народжуються славнозвісні німецькі сосиски
Їх разом із ковбасками у Німеччині - 1,5 тисячі видів.
Але як німці контролюють їхню якість?
Які штрафи загрожують за прострочене м'ясо?
І чому свинина в ФРН така дешева?
Німці їдять м’яса вдвічі більше, ніж у середньому у світі.
А саме: 60 кг м'ясних продуктів у рік на людину.
Для порівняння: в Україні це число становить 48 кг,
за даними українських аграріїв.
Коштує німецька м'ясна продукція зазвичай
дешевше, ніж у багатьох інших європейських країнах.
Приміром, ковбаски зі свинини для смаження
можна купити за 3,73 євро за кілограм.
Це приблизно 103 гривні.
Кіло фаршу зі свинини чи яловичини теж можна
взяти менш ніж за чотири євро.
Якість м’яса в Німеччині ретельно контролюють,
зокрема Федеральне міністерство з захисту прав споживачів,
Федеральний інститут аналізу ризиків та численні
регіональні установи. Щодня ветеринари
перевіряють якість м'яса на скотобійнях.
Рідше, але також регулярно перевіряються
холодильні камери та м'ясні переробні цехи.
Здійснюється незалежна сертифікація
та маркування м'ясних виробів.
Але найприскіпливіший контролер - це самі
жителі Німеччини. Якщо на упаковці, приміром,
великими літерами написано: "100% м’яса",
серед складників дрібним шрифтом - "67% м’яса",
а решта - інші наповнювачі, то німці обов’язково
поскаржаться на маркування, яке вводить в оману.
Скаргу можна подати в Товариство захисту прав споживачів
або через онлайн-платформу Lebensmittelklarheit.de.
У перекладі - "ясність про продукти".
Заявки перевіряються, і виробника змушують
усунути недоліки. Щоправда, скандали
через якість м’яса - в Німеччині теж не рідкість.
Порушникам продовольчого кодексу загрожує
штраф до 10 тисяч євро. А в серйозних випадках -
і до 20 тисяч євро та до 5 років позбавлення волі.
М’ясна індустрія - одна з важливих галузей
німецької економіки. Минулого року оборот
25 найбільших німецьких виробників м'яса
склав близько 27 мільярдів євро.
Німеччина - найбільший у Європі виробник свинини.
Щоправда, одна з основних причин
відносної дешевизни цього м’яса в тому, що
в Німеччині ще немає таких суворих приписів
щодо утримання тварин, як у багатьох її сусідів,
приміром, у скандинавських країнах або Франції.
Худобу часто утримують в надто тісних
закритих приміщеннях і перегодовують
антибіотиками, аби тварини не хворіли.
Німецькі споживачі теж стають більш свідомими.
За даними соціологів, уже понад 50% опитаних
німців при купівлі м'яса зважають радше на якість
та умови утримання тварин, а не на ціну. Втім,
звичка німців економити на всьому все ще
надто сильна, і на практиці німецькі бюргери
радо віддають перевагу дешевому м'ясу.
Ініціатива німецького уряду підвищити
податок на м'ясну продукцію задля поліпшення
умов утримання тварин поки що провалилася.